und Nordkorea hat eine ballistische
Rakete gestartet die offenbar über Japan
geflogen ist der erneute nordkoreanische
Raketentest der löst in Japan jetzt
natürlich Alarm aus Nordkorea scheint
eine Rakete abgeschossen zu haben so
hieß es in einer offiziellen Mitteilung
der Regierung und daraufhin wurden viele
Räume evakuiert und Menschen sollten
sich in ihre Keller flüchten Züge werden
in den zwei nördlichen Regionen auf
offener Strecke gestoppt das Raketen
Warnsystem des Landes aktiviert erst
gegen 8 Uhr dann glücklicherweise
Entwarnung der Chef der japanischen
Staatskanzlei informiert die Rakete sei
wohl über Japan hinweggeflogen und rund
3000 Kilometer östlich von Japan im
Pazifischen Ozean gelandet ja der
japanische premier Fumio kishida der
verurteilt den Abschuss auf Schärfste
heute morgen hat Nordkorea eine
ballistische Rakete abgefeuert die über
Japan flog und vermutlich im Pazifischen
Ozean gelandet ist der Abschuss der
einer kürzlichen Reihe von Staats durch
Nordkorea folgte ist eine rücksichtslose
Tat die ich aufs schärfste verurteile
als Reaktion auf diese Situation habe
ich die Regierung angewiesen Schäden
durch herabfallende Gegenstände zu
untersuchen Informationen gründlich zu
sammeln und zu analysieren und mit dem
betreffenden Ländern zusammenzuarbeiten
danach möchten wir sofort den Nationalen
Sicherheitsrat einberufen und uns
bemühen Informationen zu sammeln und zu
analysieren
[Musik]